foreign
let's move on to our next question we
got something from yudoy on patreon what
are your individual recommended must
read books around the topic of
minimalism what books or online articles
are you on right now of course there are
no musts there are no shoulds there are
no OTS Ryan you ought to read this book
I'm not saying you must read it but you
ought to you ought to yeah but here's
the thing I will talk about some books
and I think it's different in terms of
like I'm not reading a bunch of
minimalism books anymore now but back in
2010 I was really intrigued by this and
also blogs as well we've talked about
blogs and if there's one minimalist blog
to go to right away it's Zen habits
zenhabits.net our friendly obabouta you
know him from our first film minimalism
he also has been on the minimalist
podcast before Leo babalta his blog is
stunning it is The Benchmark for all
minimalist writing online he's been
doing it I think since
2006 so before Twitter before Facebook
was ubiquitous he was blogging regularly
if you want some simple living insights
zenhabits.net we'll put a link to that
in the show notes I do have 10 books
though for
um
people who are interested in simple
living or minimalism obviously I would
start with two of our books of course so
Jordan he'll put up the books here on
the screen in the video version if
you're watching the video version here I
mean the first two books I would say is
everything that remains and love people
use things yeah everything that remains
is a is a book that Ryan and I wrote
when we left the corporate world we
moved to Montana a cab in the middle of
nowhere and wrote about this five-year
journey of being the suit and tie
corporate guys and transforming into
minimalists and eventually the
minimalists but just letting go of all
the excess stuff and that five-year
Journey from the corporate world it
starts out in a really dark place in the
corporate world how we let go of the
corporate world we let go of the
expectations we let go of place we let
go of stuff we let go of our homes we
let go of our past lives of our
identities so that we can move forward
our most recent book A lot of people use
things is about the seven essential
relationships in our lives and so you
can check both of those out but let me
talk about some other people's books
that have really resonated with me over
the years and if you all want to butt in
I'd be happy to hear that as well so
first off uh if you're gonna buy a
minimalism book that isn't by the
minimalist I think Joshua Becker's book
things that matter oh yeah is is a
really strong book any book by Joshua
Becker but that one in particular it's
his most recent book we had him on the
podcast and we did a whole episode
called things that matter about the book
and and he was able to talk about that
and really understanding that there are
some things like actual things that
matter in our lives but then the things
that matter are usually not the things
in our lives the important things aren't
the things at all so things that matter
way back and I think 2009 I read a book
called the hundredth thing challenge by
Dave Bruno wait what's that no that
wasn't a PDF he got published on that
one yeah it was a huge book yeah
bestseller book 100 thing challenge Dave
Bruno for one one year live with just
100 items and
the thing I remember from that book that
really stood out to me is he learned
this lesson that I was able to tweeze
out of that book and carry forward with
me and that lesson is our things are not
passive
you own a thing you have to take care of
the thing you have to worry about the
thing you have to clean the thing
replace the batteries in the thing store
the thing make space for the thing
protect the thing paint the thing and
when it's all said and done you have to
replace the thing
and so our things are not passive they
play an active role in our life and so
if you want more peace you can't acquire
more things to get more peace the peace
is uncovered through this through the
act of subtracting and so the 100 thing
challenge by Dave Bruno
I would also say
how to be here by Rob Bell this isn't
necessarily A minimalist book per se but
it is this foundational book it made a
huge
had a huge role in my own life when my
wife read it she left the university
role she was working for University for
a decade and she ran and she realized
like
she had a lot of career clutter in her
life
and the book how to be here by Rob Bell
is really about
reshaping
your present and letting go of the past
so we can be here right now I buy that
book by the case and still hand it out
we have a whole stack of them downstairs
in the writer's room because it was such
a powerful short book I've read it
several times I've handed out to a bunch
of people who I know will get value from
it how to be here by Rob Bell that's a
great recommendation for minimalist
books because it's the foundation that
really I think we're trying to lead
people too which is being able to be in
the present to be in the moment to uh
yeah to to to have a clutter-free mind
yeah that's a great book because the
Clutter obviously extends well beyond
the stuff the stuff is the initial
clutter we have all these other types of
clutter including that mental clutter
you're talking about there's a great
story in there I won't run it for you
but he talks about the time where he had
a traumatic brain injury and he was
concussed and he let go of all of his
memories he was forced to yeah and that
actually brought him into the moment and
taught him this lesson he had to relearn
like the names of his family even right
and so what a powerful exercise and
letting go of the past and really being
present the next book is a book called
goodbye things you'll see it up here on
the screen if you're watching the video
version it's by fumio uh Sasaki and it's
really about the art of Japanese
minimalism so if you're looking into
that I would I'd certainly suggest that
book first goodbye things and just for
the sake of time I'll go through a few
others here Colin Wright our good friend
Colin Wright some thoughts about
relationships this is a book about
relationship clutter essentially yeah
and it is a book that I also buy by the
case and it helped in my own marriage
Bex and I when we first met we sat down
and read a chapter a day together
because these really short chapters and
they're not really chapters he calls
them policies so for example the one of
the policies in there is the I will tell
you policy so you know in a relationship
quite often you'll go up to someone say
hey what's wrong
everything okay
we don't do that and the reason we don't
do that is because I have the I will
tell you policy if something's wrong
I will tell you about it and I got that
from this book and he has these like 30
or so policies that radically have
enhanced my relationships whether it's a
romantic relationship or a business
partner relationship friendship
acquaintance whatever having these
policies set up or really setting up
boundaries for our relationships to
avoid having toxic relationships that we
have to declutter later the best way to
let go is to let go in advance right a
couple more for you real quick awareness
by Anthony Demello if you're a long time
listener to the podcast you know how
it's probably my favorite book of all
time it's not a minimalist book per se
and I think it came out in the 80s but
it is a book about
Anthony Demello is
a master of Letting Go letting go of the
expectations that create the discontent
in our lives and the experiments and the
insights he have he has in that book I
mean there's not been a book that has
had a more profound effect on me than
awareness by Anthony demella so anyone
who's an aspiring minimalist will want
to check that out as well uh here's a
practical one for you The Total Money
Makeover
by Dave Ramsey yeah if you have debt it
is the best plan that I've ever come
across to let go of financial clutter
yeah I buy that book by the case as well
and hand it out we know Dave now but I
use that book before I ever met Dave
yeah to get myself out of debt Ryan did
the same thing yeah and I've seen that
formula work for thousands and thousands
and thousands of people who are
struggling with excess Financial clutter
yeah which by the way any debt is
financial clutter yeah amen one final
book for you if you're looking for some
pictures
this is a book about sort of uh the
interior life or the interior of homes
it's by uh Natalie Walton it's called
the slow home it's about the the slow
movement which I believe stands for
sustainable
s-l-o-w organic oh what's the L local a
sustainable local organic and whole and
so it's about slow living slow Interiors
getting the excess out of the way you
can see how it makes for a peaceful home
and a few other books while we're at it
just because uh a lot of those books I
mentioned are written by by guys and
I've been reading a lot of women's
literature recently in fact we did a
whole video about this on the how to
write better Channel about uh what
people call Chiclet which uh I don't
like the term because I think it's
pejorative but um what I will say is
that I've been reading a lot of women
novelists and uh here are four that have
stood out to me over the a period of
time well Mary Carr she's actually a
memoir my favorite one of my favorite
writers so she's an I put her on the
Mount Rushmore of writers her writing is
so beautiful it's stunning uh she has a
great Memoir called the Liars Club a few
other novels that I've read recently you
have a book by Katherine Lacy called the
answers I've talked about it on this
podcast Emily gold I read this book uh
during the break uh it's called
friendship I found it I was going I was
getting a medical procedure done
overseas and I went to a coffee shop I
didn't have a book to read and I just
grabbed one off the shelf and it was
this book it's called friendship it was
so so good it's about these women who
are getting ready to turn 30 and they're
really struggling with this period of
life because they finally or feel like
they they're not children anymore but
they're still feeling those tugs of
immaturity my first novel was kind of
about this as well it was called as a
decade fades it was about a 29 year old
singer-songwriter who was letting go of
that immaturity to move forward
and finally acts of service is another
book by Lillian Fishman I think I talked
about it on the podcast from Alabama
yeah that was an added value on a
segment last year yeah yeah it's just a
a wonderful beautiful
the writing in it is so stunning uh the
gorgeous sentences the storytelling you
feel like you're a part of you're
immersed in the characters so generally
I'm bringing these four books up because
I read a lot more fiction than I read
nonfiction I don't read a whole lot of
non-fiction anymore because I find a lot
of Truth not in prescriptive non-fiction
but in the interior lives of characters
that are written about by authors who
really cherish the written word that
observation that's an episode unto
itself yeah it's good man the uh the
manner in which story delivers without
prescription the opportunity for a
piffin did you enjoy this Standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalist
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free